moi je crois à l'indépendance du québec
je crois au changement social
c'est ça ma motivation c'est de faire
qu'avec un pays équin pas les moyens
pour y arriver alors ça prend une route
à deux voies vers l'indépendance
soit on l'a fait soit on la prépare dans
un premier mandat
ce cocon de changer l'article 1 pour
qu'on réalise l'indépendance dans le
premier mandat
alors on revient au débat du parti
québécois qui avait lieu ce soir à
québec et qui portait sur l'indépendance
et sur l'éducation
tasha ce soir et à toronto daniel et à
ottawa et michel lui à assister à ce
débat il est à québec
bonsoir à vous trois alors michel on va
commencer avec vous a vu l'impression
d'assister à une lutte vraiment pour la
deuxième place entre bernard drainville
et alexandre cloutier
qu'est ce que vous retenez bah oui ben
ainslie est clair qu'ils luttent série
afin série on verra mais qui peut
vraiment la deuxième place mais je pense
que la question la plus importante à
laquelle monsieur dans un ville voulait
voir ses adversaires répondre c'est
celle qui a été adressée à monsieur
péladeau c'est à dire que qu'est-ce qui
fait s'il n'y a pas moyen de tenir un
référendum en 2018 là on voit clairement
qu'il ya un aspect deux écoles si vous
voulez il ya monsieur drainville qui
joue maintenant la carte du pragmatisme
qui qui dans le fond a l'air déjà d'être
convaincu qui serait pas capable de
chauffer la machine suffisamment pour
être en mesure de tenir un référendum
dans un premier mandat et qui commencent
déjà à essayer d'obtenir de ses
adversaires leurs solutions en code
des possibilités monsieur péladeau
refuse de répondre et je pense que
monsieur rainville n'obtiendra pas de
réponse est que lily membres du parti
québécois ce que c'est peut-être ça qui
est plus intéressant c'est pas non plus
à savoir ou même à envisager la
possibilité qui a pas de référendum car
monsieur de rêver la chauffe est trop
monsieur péladeau il y avait des huées
qui sortait je pense qu'il ya une espèce
de réflexe d'autres choix dans tout ça
tasha vous qu'est ce que vous retenez à
deux vitesses une vitesse on sait plus
écoutez monsieur péladeau et
effectivement on n'a pas répondu à la
question et à maintes reprises a été
posée à même un moment aussi on a posé
la question et ensuite les autres
intervenants ont tous sauté sur la
question sans lui laisser même l'espace
de réponse un peu étrange
c'est un peu comme si on veut pas
vraiment savoir parce que on attend tout
ce que monsieur péladeau va remporter
cette course est le maître le plus dans
l'embarras de ne pas répondre à la
question je passe je n'étais pas
surprise qu'ils avaient des huées parce
que on veut pas on veut pas voir que
l'amp erreur n'a pas de vêtements quoi
et c'est un peu le cas ici je n'étais
vraiment pas impressionné du tout il y
avait beaucoup de clichés et pop
beaucoup de réponses effectivement
daniel vous qu'est ce que vous avez
retenu
évidemment ils sont tous pour
l'indépendance mais chacun son chemin
pour y arriver
est ce qu'il ya un rapprochement
possible et rapprochement écouter ils
vont tous dans la même direction c'est
le problème ce qu'ils savent pas comment
y aller et ce serait présomptueux aussi
de dire voilà ce qu'on va faire
exactement 3 en politique c'est une
éternité
et si on gagne la prochaine élection il
faut ensuite faire le référendum on
parle de quatre ou cinq ans ya tellement
de choses qui peuvent arriver d'ici cinq
ans tout ce débat là me semble très
hypothétique alors tous les québécois
sont préoccupés par la rigueur
budgétaire par les compressions du
gouvernement couillard mène alors que
tout le débat tourne autour de ça on
fait un débat en vente ce que nous
sommes indépendants ce quelque chose
d'hypothétique qui pourrait arriver dans
ces cas est ce que est ce que est ce que
je pense que michel raison
les militants du parti québécois c'est
des gens intelligents ils savent très
bien que de 0 aujourd'hui on va faire un
référendum de la première année après la
prédilection c'est pas responsables
martin goyette peut dire ah c'est son
choix elle a décidé de jouer cette carte
là
la joue bien sauf que c'est pas réaliste
c'est pas comme ça que ça va se passer
il ya peut-être d'autres choses qui
peuvent arriver moi je suis je suis
d'accord avec pierre karl péladeau de
bâton pas de cartes sur la table
concourront pour jouer dans l'année donc
michel g qu'est ce qu'il faut comprendre
quand même de cette stratégie il a cité
parisot ce soir monsieur péladeau à 10
ans pas de stratégie ouverte donc c'est
ça oui ben monsieur pères
oui monsieur parizeau c'est toujours ça
mais lui il y avait été parfaitement
claires et si quelqu'un l'époque avait
dit écoutez on en parle comme ce pas
resort était le premier du nom non
écoutez là pour avoir un référendum
mobiliser les gens il faut absolument
avoir une date
alors monsieur parizeau faut pas
toujours écouter ce qu'ils disent
regardez plutôt ce qu'il a fait mais je
pense qu'il ya plus qu'une volonté chez
les militants de garder l'avenir ouvert
je pense qu'un refus d'envisager toute
possibilité qu'il ne puisse pas y en
avoir de référendum dans un premier
mandat pour beaucoup de gens monsieur
péladeau est vraiment l'ultime chance
d'en tenir un alors ils veulent même pas
imaginer qu'ils puissent ne pas y en
avoir un c'est plus que refus de faire
place nette et j'ouvre alors qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé du ton des échanges
d'achat il y avait quand même du un
temps assez acrimonieux un peu entendre
bernard drainville et alexandre cloutier
oui c'était la commune yeux mais c'est
le foot il n'avait pas beaucoup de voix
parfois mais c'était aussi je pense
c'était vraiment comme on était aux
années 90 c'était là même le même sort
de débats sur est-ce qu'on va garder la
monnaie ce qu'on va le dollar canadien
qu'est ce qui va arriver avec tous les
ressources de l'état s'était un peu
fatiguant honnêtement et je sais que
c'est des questions qui doivent être
débattues dans le cas que le québec se
sépare mais encore c'est le même débat
prématuré qu'on fait avant même que la
décision est prise c'est finalement
c'est comme un référendum si nécessaire
mais pas nécessairement un référendum
c'est cela à quoi on aboutit c'est un
cercle vicieux
tout le temps daniel sur le ton des
échanges oui tout est amusant votre
cloutier dréville entre d'arrivée les
péladeau ça fait ça fait un très bon
spectacle
convaincus qu'ils sont sincères aussi
sauf que ça ne va pas très loin écoutez
c'est une course à la direction qui est
beaucoup trop longue
dès le départ tout le monde est tenu
pour acquis que pierre karl péladeau à
la gagner
beaucoup de suspense même sur la
question de l'indépendance comment on la
fera il ya pas beaucoup de suspense
c'est un débat qui sera en vase clos ça
ne touche pas beaucoup la population le
nombre de membres du parti québécois a
pas augmenté beaucoup il n'y a pas eu de
facteurs pierre karl péladeau pour faire
exploser le membership du parti bref
j'ai l'impression que dès qu'ils
seraient élus pierre karl péladeau ou
enfin le prochain chef du parti
québécois pardonnez-moi va s'attaquer
aux vrais problèmes qui sont sur
l'économie qui sont ceux de la fiscalité
québécoise entrer dans le débat de pelé
pied avec fédé couillard sur les
questions de rigueur budgétaire bon une
dernière petite question là-dessus la
question qu'on veut pas poser mais qu'on
pose quand même
donc il s'en est le mieux sorti michel
vous qui étiez là bas qui fait sentir
vraiment mais moi je pense que c'est
monsieur bailly ville qui à tout le
moins posée les meilleures questions qui
a mené le jeu de ce débat il y aura
obtenu les réponses qu'ils voulaient
mais je pense que c'est lui qui a
vraiment donné le ton très bien alors on
va passer à notre autre sujet
aujourd'hui sur la scène fédérale
depuis qu'il est au pouvoir le
gouvernement s'ils veulent râpeux a subi
une série de défaites devant la cour
suprême cette semaine encore le plus
haut tribunal du pays a rejeté l'un des
volets du programme sur la loi et
l'ordre du gouvernement celui des peines
minimales obligatoires pour possession
d'armes à feu prohibée mais est ce
vraiment une si mauvaise nouvelle que ça
pour les conservateurs daniel je vais
commencer avec vous sur ce volet là
c'est une sa neuvième revers pour le
gouvernement rappeur en cour suprême à
quoi est-ce qu'on assiste exactement on
assiste à une cour suprême qui a entre
les mains un outil de travail qui lui a
été donnée par pierre elliott trudeau
qui s'appelle la charte des droits et
libertés
et c'est là dessus que se baser juge
pour rendre leur jugement le
gouvernement harper a décidé qu'il y
avait un problème majeur de criminalité
au canada alors que les 16 sec nous
indiquent le contraire les juges de la
cour suprême
il est voilée c'est cissé qui savent que
la criminalité diminue au canada ils
savent que ce gouvernement là à un ordre
du jour très très très très idéologique
et c'est la raison pour laquelle ils
rendent des décisions en se basant sur
la charte canadienne des droits et
libertés
c'est ce qu'ils font depuis qu'elle est
adoptée c'est ce qu'ils vont continuer
de faire sept des neuf juges de la cour
suprême ont été nommés par simona pleut
quand ça c'est qu'ils donnent pas raison
au gouvernement conservateur est ce qu
est ce qu est ce qu il
en plus elles étaient des gens qu'ils
ont probablement jeunes y croire sauf
que c'est peut-être aussi que le
gouvernement conservateur a pas compris
comment évoluer la société canadienne et
que les jeux ont compris tâche est ce
qu'on peut parler d'un affrontement de
la cour suprême et le gouvernement est
ce qu'on peut aller jusque là
ben oui et je pense qu'il ya
certainement un côté politique la cour
suprême qu'on n'a pas vue depuis
longtemps mais j'ai pas complètement
d'accord avec daniel que c'est seulement
sur la charte que la courbe à ces
décisions
les décisions sur le sénat c'était
vraiment une claque dans la face de
monsieur harper il s'était pas basée sur
la chair du tout était basé sur un
raisonnement un peu torturé certains ont
dit un peu comme le raisonnement de dans
le cas de monsieur nadon et c'est la
même juge la zone exactement la
nomination du sénat dont je pense était
vraiment la goutte qui a fait déborder
le vase qui a fait plus très la cour
parce qu'ils ont ils ont pensé que
monsieur râpeux voulait leur imposer
quelqu'un qui n'était pas nécessairement
qualifiée selon la loi à la cour alors
c'est là vraiment on a vu tout
l'animosité entre monsieur et madame
jacqueline qui est sorti après ça des
accusations qu'on a jamais en chef
absolument et c'est là je pense vraiment
on voit que oui il ya une politisation
de la cour mais les conservateurs
écoutent ils sont toujours en guerre
avec la charte et la cour en général ils
pensent que c'est la cour utilise la
charte comme une arme contre les le
conservatisme
alors chaque fois que ça arrive il
envoie des lettres et demande aux
conservateurs envoyer de l'argent parce
que effectivement c'est la cour qui
frustre nos ambitions faut il faut aller
plus loin donc politiquement c'est
peut-être pas une mauvaise si mauvaise
nouvelle pour eux c'est une perte
politique mais en même temps c'est un
gain partisans michel un affrontement
mais on a su cela oui il ya plusieurs
niveaux il ya évidemment l'animosité
personnel entre monsieur à peu et madame
mclachlan il ya aussi deux conception
d'applications de justice là dedans il y
en a une approche conservatrice qu'il
approche punitive oisive et l'autre
approche qui est plutôt celle de
l'intégration qui dit que c'est pas
parce qu'on tape plus fort sur quelqu'un
qu'on va le ramener à la raison et mais
en toile de fond il ya parce que c'est
pas nouveau ce l'affrontement
entre deux conceptions qui essaient du
gouvernement par les juges qui cueille
évidemment été renforcé par l'adoption
de la charte et le pouvoir qui doit être
celui des élus c'est bien antérieure à
monsieur harper il ya des premiers
ministres qui étaient pas nécessairement
des conservateurs je n'ai eu un autre
conservateur monsieur loïc qui ont
souvent dit que quitte à d'abord
favorable à la clause nonobstant et qui
disait faudrait l'utiliser plus souvent
précisément pour démontrer que ce sont
les élus qui doivent mener et si
monsieur harper voulait à ce point
imposer son point de vue dans la
question qui nous occupe les peines
minimales
il pourrait très bien utiliser la clause
nonobstant l'article 12 qui est concerné
et retombe sous le possibilité de de la
contourner par la clause dérogatoire à
la met sur un peu le fera pas parce que
je pense qu'il aime faire que ce débat
se faire sur nous parce que ça plaît à
sa base daniel m'a souvent des défaites
dont le gouvernement conservateur au
fond ce n'est pas vraiment une sur le
plan politique donc à la non non
absolument pas et comme disait sacha ça
donne des munitions stephen harper va
les voir les serbes il va leur envoyer
cette méchante cour suprême nous encore
mis des bâtons dans les roues pour faire
ce qu'on veut et cetera sauf que si vous
remontez dans l'histoire canadienne
jusqu'à pierre elliott trudeau n'allons
pas trop loin pour pas découragé
personne à chaque fois qu'il ya eu des
décisions importantes à prendre que ce
soit sur le rapatriement de la
constitution
que ce soit sur la légalité du
référendum d'indépendance du québec que
ce soit sur le sénat
que ce soit sur la prostitution sur
l'avortement les politiciens soient
capables de prendre ces décisions alors
qu'est ce qu'ils font et s'en remettre à
la cour suprême à chaque fois et moi je
à la lumière de ce qui s'est passé au
saguenay le jugement sur la faune la
prière j'ai l'impression que tout le
débat sur l'immigration la place des
immigrants la place de la religion ou
encore se décide et non pas dans des
débats sur des chartes de la laïcité
qu'on avait vu au québec mais c'est la
cour suprême qui encore une fois va
décider comment ça devrait se passer au
cargö heureusement la charte des droits
et libertés
ouais donc au fond d'achats sur le jeu
revient toujours au plan politique la
pour le gouvernement ce qui est
important au fond c'est d'appliquer son
programme et ensuite ce qui peut se
passer alors qu'on se prenne ou pas
c'est moi important pour lui
ça le gouvernement certainement aimerait
aller à sa base de dire depuis qu'on est
élu on a fait et qui grèvent les aides
sur notre plan pour combattre la
criminalité mais en même temps même si
la cour suprême rend vers certaines
dispositions ça ne veut pas dire que le
gouvernement peut pas trouver une autre
façon peut-être de les ramener et en
même temps dire à la population ou à la
base conservatrice
écoutez il faut nous donner justement
une majorité plus forte qu'il faut nous
donner d'autres outils pour qu'on puisse
revenir et c'est tenter une autre fois
c'est c'est une cour suprême je pense
qui comme j'ai dit est devenue politisée
mais aussi c'est vrai que la charte des
libertés au nom très souvent ils
décisions qui sont prises contre les
conservateurs très bien alors merci ça
et quand vous avez été encore une fois
très éclairant tous les trois merci
beaucoup à la semaine prochaine